[Musique]
échauffement de rigueur et en musique à
quelques minutes du grand départ mais
ici ce n'est pas la gagne qui motive les
troupes juste le plaisir du sport c'est
maintenant que je fais la marche
nordique au club de saint cyr sur loire
qu'un super club hyper dynamique et
c'est un super sport
par contre cherche pas le classement
mais bon je suis pas la première
et c'est parti pour 10 km au rythme des
bâtons de marche à peine ans qu'il est
là rue des tanneurs nos sportifs partent
à l'assaut du pont napoléon sous le
regard et les encouragements de quelques
maris pas peu fiers de leur moitié
je citais attendu ma femme là sur le 10
km marche nordique spectateurs et
supporters et supporters et je fais des
vins après mais pour le coup à faire
voilà oui les chaussures ya que les
chaussures pour le moment vous êtes venu
supporter quelqu'un bat mon épouse en
fait avec ma fille c'est votre chienne
ah bah oui carrément sur tous les plans
mais pas le temps de s'attendrir pour
ses 350 coureurs nordique une boucle par
saint cyr sur loire et puis tous en
reviennent par le pont de file de l'île
aucard et sa ligne d'arrivée se profile
une heure et sept minutes seulement pour
les grands gagnants
je l'aimé
bien
mais je suis contente j'ai toujours fait
les 10 ou 20 km et là c'est vraiment
génial qu'on a mis la marche ont des
dents département on est quand même
beaucoup à faire ce sport première fois
que la marche nordique s'inviter à
l'événement du marathon et des 10 et 20
km l'essai est transformé au la main on
est vraiment dans les nouvelles
pratiques avec ce côté marche nordique
dynamique le beau geste et aussi la
compétition un peu hors compétition et
loisirs en même temps sans que ça attire
beaucoup de monde 350 participants et
c'est vraiment très très chouette c'est
vraiment un beau succès
un succès qui devrait susciter quelques
vocations pour ce sport doux convivial
en tout cas c'est promis ils reviendront
tous l'année prochaine